thank you uh federo and thank you
organizers um thank you all for being
here still I know it's still late
afternoon so you might be feeling a
little bit tired or hungry um but thank
you for being here
nevertheless um consider this situation
um we just have an exchange economy with
indivisible objects and unit demand um
I'm more used to an econ audience so for
this matching audience um this is just
exactly the shapley scarf house swap
setting and suppose we observe revealed
preferences style kind of aggregate
matching data I see the agents the agent
types um and this is meaning that we
observe sets of agents who share the
same preferences I'll say a little bit
more about this in a little bit um we
have houses with potentially multiple
copies of each
house and we observe agents endowments
and
allocations what's unobserved um are the
preferences so even though I observe
agent types um and groups of agents that
share the same preferences I don't
actually observe the preferences these
are unknown to
me the central question is this could
The observed economy be in equilibrium
and here I'll be working with the
core so here's an example of the kind of
data that might be seen um we have types
I observe their owned house and their
finally assigned house
and just how many are in this category
so for example here there are three
agents of type one meaning they all
share the same preference which is
unknown to me um and I observe their
owned house and their allocated
house I'll just talk a bit more about
the setting um I'm really happy with
this presentation order because now I
can just kind of tell you um very little
about the core you already know what it
is um in summary it's group stable no
group would defect and retrade their own
endowments it happens also also to be
Paro
optimal and also there's no explicit
prices or transfers necessary um for
this equilibrium
concept if you prefer in my model I'll
show that it happens to be equivalent to
competitive equilibrium um so if you
just want to think about that you can
think about that instead just remember
there's no prices or transfers inherent
in this
model and exchange economy with unit
demand um this really models kind of
large discret Goods with fuzzy
allocation
processes um there's no explicit price
clearing the market but there's some
ownership um people can kind of trade
their
endowments and this a stylized version
of some important markets that we've
already seen today there's Public School
assignment organ exchange course
assignment and housing
allocation now why should we care
whether a market in the
core one it might be the object of
interest in and of itself we're just
concerned whether the economy is stable
and
efficient um two equilibrium might be
necessary for other analyses such as
analysis of the
preferences we can use it to form ex Ane
predictions for the market so if we know
when the observables are consistent with
the core even before the market is
executed we can have at least some
restrictions on what we should
see and there's another interpretation
that's a little bit subtle um there's
auditability in the sense of uh gregori
Aram Gregorian and
Müller
um Suppose there is a centralized
mechanism used that claims to lead to
the core but the implementer won't tell
us anything about it and we only observe
um kind of the agents types and
allocations if we can find conditions
for whether for when the observables are
consistent with the core
then we have a way to kind of audit this
unknown mechanism with very little
information and finally more towards
economics um this is building on the sun
and shine mental and de Bru anything
goes theorem so I'll show you hopefully
um that we do indeed find some real
testable implications in this setting um
so this is not the same setting as sonan
Mel and the breu but it's in the same
style um and I'll hopefully convince you
that um with this setup it's no longer
anything
goes let me say a bit more about the
agent types um this is an assumption
that's akin to kind of assuming that the
preferences are solely a function of
some observables X um for example it
might be demographic characteristics
that I observe about the
agents um phrased another way we can
fully condition any heterogenity away on
X um finally let me just say that this
is a model of ordinal rankings so if it
helps you feel kind of psychologically
more comfortable um small Cardinal
differences are allowed as long as they
generate the same ordinal
ranking this is really the identifying
assumption that gives content to the
question um something of this flavor is
required um you can probably see that
allowing full individual heterogenity
makes this question
trivial um lastly this is really a an
assumption that's kind of in the style
of revealed preferences and ex in
exchange I'll get results that are
completely non-parametric so I won't
assume any functional form of the
utility generating these
rankings lastly the analyst has some
choice if indeed there's some
observables that are being binned to
produce these types um the analyst has a
choice between kind of coarser types
with stronger implications and finer
types with weaker implications so this
is an informal statement but the analyst
is kind of free to choose what um they
feel the correct tradeoff
is
just a bit about the literature um
obviously there's the matching
literature the model is due to shapl and
scarf um this paper is closely related
to kind of very few things and Loosely
related to a lot of things um there's
Federico's paper at Lees on the revealed
preferences of kind of stable marriage
matching and I'll come back to this if
we have time at the
end here's a preview of the results I'll
present to you graph
construction that's a tractable
representation of The observed economy
and I can use this construction to
decompose the market into market
segments that partition the economy um
since patina went before me I'll tell
you that these happen to be the sec's of
the graph that I'll
construct and the results for
rationalizability are this remember that
I observe the agents types endowments
and
allocations I'll find if and only if
conditions that characterize which
Market outcomes can be in the
core informally speaking it's this the
observables are rationalizable if and
only if within each market segment of
the economy agents of the same type
receive the same
house I'll present the formal model
now we have agent types um one through a
and individual agents just a bit about
the notation here I'm using um the
first kind of digit of individual agents
as the type and the second is just an
individual identifier so 1 a and 1B will
be two different agents of the same
type I'll represent houses as the
standard unit vectors um so you can
imagine the first Vector is just house
number
one and an allocation um sorry an
endowment I just observe every agent
endowed with one of these houses and an
allocation this is just conservation of
house Mass I'm not throwing anything
away or apparating
anything and the preferences are this
each agent type has strict preferences
over the houses okay so the preference
here is indexed by I which is an agent
type just to reiterate this means that
agents 1 a and 1B have the same
preference which is going to be
unobserved to me but I know they have
the same strict preference over the
houses but they can have different
endowments they can have different
endowments
yes okay here's a definition of the
strong core um I can kind of Bree
through
this uh but again the strong core is or
sorry an allocation is in the strong
core for some preference profile if
there's no blocking Coalition and a
blocking Coalition is a subset of agents
and a sub allocation such that it's
feasible
everyone's weekly better off and at
least one person is strictly better
off okay so this is the exact same
definition as presented in betina's
talk an economy is the tupal of
observables again that's the agents
agent types the agents the houses
endowments and allocation so what's
missing here is the preferences I do not
observe the preferences an economy is
rationalizable if there exists some
preference profile such such that the
allocation in the
core and here's the definition of strong
connected components again I'll just
Breeze right through this um just so
we're all on the same page a strong
connected component is a maximal subset
of vertices such that there are paths
between any two vertices okay this
contrasts with the we components because
um I and J I Need a path from I to J and
a path from J to
I and here's just an example of a graph
partitioned into the strong connected
components a general result is that any
directed graph has a unique partition
into strongly connected
components here's the main graph
construction that I work with um this is
a representation of the information that
I
observe construct the graph this
way each agent is a
vertex and draw an arc from agent ik to
all other agents I prime K Prime who are
endowed with
xik okay so I'm drawing an arc from
myself to all copies of the object that
I
receive the secc's of this graph
partition the market into um what I
called market segments that only only
interact among themselves I'll give you
an example here this is the same example
that I showed you at the beginning of
the talk um for agent One agent one
receives house number two so I'll draw
an arc from agent one to everyone
endowed with house number two that's 1B
and 2 a so I have two arcs
here and here's the rest of the
arcs any questions about that
construction you don't uh get the
construction won't get anything else I'm
about to
say okay so it's fairly simple um but
it's a little bit subtle I want to
emphasize that um this is not really a
representation of the allocation um in
particular only one of these arcs would
be realized in an actual allocation um
but this is representing kind of all the
information that I
see here's the main result on
rationalizability
fix an economy and consider the graph
that I just
drew the economy is rationalizable if
and only if for agents of the same type
ik ik Prime in the same SEC we have that
their allocated objects are the
same okay um and just as a remark this
is easy to check um you can find the
sec's in linear time uh we're linears in
the vertices and the edges so if you
prefer to just think about the agents
that would be polinomial
um and back to the example the only
thing to check here is that 1 a and 1 B
who are in the same SEC have to receive
the same object and indeed here they do
so this is rationalizable there's
nothing else to check here um 2 a and 3A
are the only agents of their type in
this
SEC and 1 C and 2B are also the only
agents of their type in this SEC so
there's nothing else to
check I'll give you a proof sketch
um you know we've been dealing a lot
with ordinal preferences so far so I'm
going to commit a cardinal sin and show
you proof by picture um but first I'll
just prove some facts about this graph
that I
constructed um the first fact is that
all copies of a house are in the same
SEC um the reason is this an agent
points to all copies of the allocated
house so here again 1A is pointing to
both copies of H2
every node is in at least one cycle this
is just true kind of of exchanged
economies of representations like this
um so I'm going to call a self Loop a
cycle here one B is in a cycle and 1 a
is also in a cycle or rather two A's in
a
cycle and lastly the Cycles point at
each other since X ik is common and
everyone's poting at all copies of this
object okay so that puts together both
copies of H2 into the same
SEC the second fact is that the sccs and
undirected components of this graph
coincide um kind of intuitiv intuitively
what this gives us is that the secs are
the maximal trading Cycles so I've
highlighted here kind of the largest
Possible Trading cycle that can be um
implemented in this
economy um so is unique uh one
implication of this result is that when
you draw this
graph uh you can find the maximal
trading cycles that are implementable
and this is actually a unique
result um I can use this to partition
the economy into the market segments and
these market segments contain all the
important information that I
need so here some of the intuition of
the
condition um
the easiest intuition is just from a
competitive equilibrium kind of
equivalence um Roth and P white and Waco
show that um this allocation X is in the
strong
core if the allocation X is in the
strong core then it's also competitive
equilibrium allocation for some price um
the price is not inherent it's just out
there kind of floating but it is a
competitive equilibrium
allocation if the allocation is
rationalizable then it must also be a
competitive equilibrium for some price
and some preference
profile um all housed in the same SEC
should have the same price and all
agents in the same SEC have the same
budget so if we have the same
preferences and we have the same budget
we should be able to buy the same
object obviously this is an informal
proof um Devil's in details and the
details are in the paper but we'll move
along a PR sketch of the if Direction um
is constructive
I'm going to find a preference profile
that puts the allocation in the
core first just find the decomposition
to
sec's and pick an arbitrary order of
secc's we're going to assign preferences
in this arbitrary order so in the first
SEC say what everyone receives is their
favorite thing in the second
SEC um say what they receive there's a
is their favorite thing if possible this
might not be possible because they might
have been assigned in the first I in
which case say that's the second
favorite
thing um there's two important reasons
that this works the first is that if we
have two agents of the same type in the
same SEC they receive the same object by
assumption so this is well defined at
each
step the second reason is that all
copies of the same house end up in the
same SEC so this procedure is well
defined across steps I never have to
worry about reassigning a house to a
different preference slot
later and argument that this doesn't
create blocking coalitions is similar to
Giles proof for
TTC so this is the same example before
um I've just picked an arbitrary order
of the sec's we'll say the left one is
first the right one is
second and I say in the uh first
SEC the favorite thing is just what they
received and the second sec say their
favorite things is what they received if
possible here it's not possible for
either agent because type one already
showed up here and type two already
showed up here so that's their second
favorite
thing and this preference profile um you
can probably see rationalizes the
allocation as in the
core um I'll just summarize the results
briefly uh what have we done I started
out with the question what are the
testable implications of the core in an
exchange econ
economy exchange economies with unit
demand are important and foundational
models of economies um they Model A lot
of situations that um are very important
such as literal house allocation um
organ exchange and school
assignment I have an easyto check and
intuitive characterization for
rationalizability and this goes on
earlier anything goes
results
um we can check consistency with
equilibri
and we might care about this in and of
itself um just for welfare claims or
efficiency claims of the market or we
might want to audit whatever process
produced
this we can also check this if we care
about other analysis that requires
equilibrium such as analysis of the
preferences and we can also form at
least some ex anti predictions for
Market outcomes before the Market's even
executed I have some results in the
paper um and since we saved so much time
not explaining sec's in the core I'll
show you a little bit um I also have an
analogus result for um the setting with
monetary
transfers basically the same notation
the only addition is that now an
endowment is a house and an amount of
money and an allocation is a house and
some amount of money again we don't
destroy any houses or gain any houses
and we don't uh sorry this in equalities
the wrong way we don't uh create any
money out of
nowhere again
what that's a good question
um so a type
um we should think of settings where
preferen is strongly determined or sorry
where preferences are strongly
determined by something we observe I
think
um this is actually not a bad model of a
lot of situations so in the hous example
um say I observe your socioeconomic
characteristics your wealth level where
you work
etc um everyone with the same
observables or bin observables of that
has the same preference so
um everyone of the same kind of wealth
working in the same let say Place
similar job you have the same preference
for houses and this might be kind of
where your house is located
um something of that
flavor then you are
also assuming that same typ are
eventually going to get the
same
um uh so
it's and one can they have different
houseside they can yes um
that is mediated through you are growing
your s Yes
actually point out arrows to the same
houses from both
typ that's true
um there uh it's not necessary though um
there's also a type 1 C here who
receives a different house um so it's
not true that every agent of the same
it's not true that all type 1 agents end
up in the same sec
that's mediated through their endowment
if they have the same endowment then
definitely they end up in the same SEC
but that's um uh there are other cases
as well
yeah does that answer your question
thank
you I'll just briefly show you this
result um without proof um introducing
monetary transfers and preferences are
Quasi linear um
there's some utility for the house and
just
money I modify the graph to just add net
payments to the Arc Length so now this
is a weighted directed graph um for
example agent
1A net pays $2 I don't know to whom just
pays to the economy $2 and I'll add that
to the arc lengths that's the only
change here's the main
result this economy with transfers
um is rationalizable if and only if
there exists a price
Vector
um looking like this and this is exactly
the price Vector that would support this
economy as a competitive equilibrium
it's also equivalent to the graph having
no cycles of positive
length um so you see here this is
actually rationalizable if we look at
every cycle including self Loops um this
has zero length this has zero length
this has zero length and so on
um so this is rationalizable as
well again no time to even kind of show
you a proof sketch um but we have these
three these two equivalent conditions um
and all the full details are in the
paper so yes so this one is reminiscent
of if you do sun shine the but you allow
yourself to observe endowments in to
where get
something there will be a zero on the
right side because
it's suppose that I take a an exchange
economy a general exchange economy I
observe the Endor everyone and end you
don't get characterization like this in
terms of whether this can be competitive
equilibrium
okay I'm sorry I don't have any specific
thoughts on that right now um maybe we
can talk after I would appreciate
that I'll just conclude um also in the
paper I have an econometric method to
estimate utility parameters so if we
observe data that consists of multiple
aggregate matchings with the same types
um and you're willing to give a
functional form for the data I can also
estimate the utility parameters of that
um and that comes from a series of
inequalities
um uh stability implies a series of
inequalities which I can estimate
um yeah uh thank you oh I'm happy to
take any questions or comments um by
email after
this
question I one
question